Krylo quantum diagonalization or KQD for short refers to solving a matrix value
problem by projecting the matrix into a subspace prepared on a quantum computer consistent with the Kryof method a
powerful approach from classical linear algebra. Throughout this video we'll explore what the Kryoff method is useful
and how and when to implement it on quantum computers.
So what is the Kryoff method? Suppose we have a matrix H related to a scientific or business endeavor with n rows and n
columns. We're interested in the lowest igen value e 0 and the corresponding igen vector size 0. Let's define an
initial vector v which might be motivated by the structure of h or might be entirely random. The krylov subspace
of order r which we write k r is generated by acting with h on this
initial vector r minus one times adding the result of each subsequent h action
to the set of spanning vectors that is kr is the space spanned by the vectors v
hv h squ and so on. These vectors will not generally be orthogonal.
Classically, we often carry out an orthogonalization process very much like the Graham Schmidt procedure. You start
by normalizing the initial vector V and call the result V 0. Then for the next vector HV, you subtract off its
projection onto V 0 to make the two vectors orthogonal. You then normalize the result. You continue like this,
acting again with H and making the result orthogonal to all previously added vectors until you've built up R
orthonormalized vectors required to span your Rdimensional Kryof subspace.
Once you have this subspace, you project your matrix onto it and diagonalize the smaller projected matrix. There are
subtleties and extensions, but that is a Krylov method at its simplest level.
To get a better sense of how this works, let's look at a trivial example. If H is this matrix and V is chosen to be this
vector, then we would start by normalizing V. To generate the second vector in a Krylooff subspace, we act
once with H on our initial vector and then make that result orthogonal to V 0.
A little algebra yields this for V1.
This is not useful for such small matrices and would not typically stop at a kryof dimension of two. But if we were
to project H onto our new kryoff space K2, we would do this using a matrix V
which has a Kryof vector for each column and its transpose conjugate which has Kryoff vectors for rows. We would then
obtain this matrix.
This matrix technically has lower dimension than our original. Obviously, this reduction is not useful at this
scale. This method is intended for reducing matrices with many thousands or even millions of rows and columns down
to just a handful. So why are Krylov methods useful? It turns out that this simple prescription
of operator action is often the most efficient way to approach the lowest value state or ground state of a matrix
operator. Let's make this a bit more explicit though we'll leave a full proof to the accompanying text. We wish to
solve a problem of the form h acting on the vector x gives us some constant times the vector x. Let's start with a
guess of our igen vector x0. This is just an approximate solution. It has error which we call e 0. Now we want to
make an update of this guess which we'll call x1 which we hope improves our approximation. We can express this as
the original x0 plus some correction p 0 which is yet to be determined. We can
repeat this process iteratively adding more and more correction vectors pi.
Obviously we want our error to be reduced but it isn't just the state that we care about. We also care about the
action of h on that state. So the quantity we really want to minimize is the h norm of this error or the norm of
the action of h on this error.
Now we can see that this is an expression involving p 0 and we can ask ourselves what choices of p minimize
this h norm of the error most efficiently. From what space should we select the correction? Under certain
conditions such as when h is symmetric and positive definite, choosing the first r corrections from within kr turns
out to be optimal. In simpler terms, we need some way of preparing a good subspace onto which we
can project our Hamiltonian. And in many cases, the Krylooff subspace is the space spanned by the vectors of most
efficient corrections to our initial guess.
For a real proof, see the text accompanying this video.
Everything we've described so far can be done classically. So, how and when would we use a quantum computer?
For very large matrices, the Kryoff method can require long computing times and large amounts of memory. The time
required for matrix operation of H on V scales like N squared in the worst case.
And this is done for every vector we want in our subspace. The subspace dimension R is usually not a significant
fraction of N and often scales like log of N. So generating all vectors scales
like order N^2 log N.
Although there are other steps like orthogonalization, this is the dominant scaling to keep in mind.
Quantum computing allows us to change what attributes of the problem determine the scaling of the time and resources
required. Instead of dependence on matrix size n across the board, we'll see things like the number of shots and
the number of non-commuting poly terms that make up a Hamiltonian.
Let's explore how this works.
Recall that the operator that time evolves a quantum state is the exponential of iH over h bar. And it's
very common, especially in quantum computing, to drop the h bar from the notation.
One way of understanding and even realizing such an exponential function of an operator is to look at its foyer
series expansion. Note that this operation acting on some initial vector V yields a sum of terms
with increasing powers of H applied to the initial state. It looks like we can just make our Kryoff subspace by time
evolving our initial guess state. And that's almost true. The caveat is in
realizing the time evolution on a real quantum computer. Many of the terms in the Hamiltonian will not commute with
each other. So while some simple exponential operators like e to the negative i z correspond to simple
circuits general hamiltonians do not and since they contain non-commuting terms
we can't simply decompose the exponential into a product of simple ones the way we can with numbers. So
this is not trivial but this is a wellstudied process in quantum computing. We carry out time evolution
on quantum computers using a process called trotterization which in itself is a rich subject. But at a very high level
by breaking the time evolution into small steps say M steps we limit the effects of the non-commutativity of
terms. Let us call the krylov subspace of order r that we generated in the classical context using powers of h
directly the power kryov subspace kpr.
Now we generate a similar space using the unitary time evolution operator u given by the exponential of iht.
We'll refer to this as the unitary kryov space kur.
The power krylov subspace kpr that we use classically can't be generated directly on a quantum computer as h is
not a unitary operator. Using the unitary krylo subspace can be shown to give similar convergence
guarantees as the power kryov subspace.
Specifically, the ground state error converges efficiently as long as the initial state V has overlap with the
true ground state that is not exponentially vanishing and as long as there's a sufficient gap between igen
states. Here powers of u become different time steps. The kith power of u is stepping
forward by a time k * dt.
We can label the element of the subspace that is time evolved for a total time kdt as s sub k. We can project our
Hamiltonian H onto the unitary kryoff subspace kur. In other words, we
calculate each matrix element of h in the kur basis. We'll refer to this
projected matrix as h till day. The matrix elements of H till day are given by these expectation values which can be
estimated using the quantum computer.
Keep in mind that H can be written as a sum of poly operators on different cubits and that not all poly operators
can be measured simultaneously. We can sort the poly terms into groups of commuting terms and measure all of
those at once. But we may need many such groups to cover all the terms. So the number of distinct commuting groups into
which the terms can be partitioned ngcp becomes important. If we use a unitary krylo subspace of dimension r the
resulting matrix will have dimensions r * r. If r is much less than n then we've
made useful progress and typically r is much less than 100 meaning we can diagonalize this easily on a classical
computer. But recall that s n and s m will not generally be orthogonal. It is
sometimes possible to diagonalize a matrix in a non-orththogonal basis. But there are numerical and physical reasons
for first changing to an orthogonal basis. Hence we solve a generalized igen value problem using the gram matrix s.
The mn element of the gram matrix is given by the inner product of s m on cn.
Both the elements of H till day and S are calculated using a hatamart test.
The generalized igen value problem then becomes this.
As noted above, the dimension of the unitary krylo subspace R is exponentially smaller than our initial
matrix dimension N. So this value problem is simple to solve classically.
To recap, we start with a reference state, then evolve it for different periods of time to generate the unitary
krylov subspace. We project our Hamiltonian onto that subspace and we also estimate the overlaps of the
subspace vectors. Finally, we solve the lower dimensional generalized value problem classically. Let's compare what
determines computational costs of using the kryoff technique classically and quantum mechanically. We sketched this
already for the classical version and there are not perfect analoges between classical and quantum approaches for all steps. But this table collects some
scaling of different steps for consideration. Recall that Hamiltonians generally have terms that cannot be simultaneously measured because they do
not commute. We sort terms in the Hamiltonian into groups of commuting poly operators that can all be measured simultaneously and we may require many
such groups to account for all the terms that do not commute. To build up H till day on a quantum computer requires
separate measurements for each group of commuting poly strings in the Hamiltonian. And each of those require many shots. We must do this for R
squared different matrix elements corresponding to R squar combinations of different time evolution factors. There
are sometimes ways to reduce this. But in this rough treatment, the time required for this scales roughly like
the number of shots times the number of groups of commuting poly terms* r^ 2.
The elements of s must be estimated which scales like the number of shots
per cubed. We see that quantum kryof diagonalization may be useful in cases where the number of commuting poly
groupoups in the Hamiltonian is relatively small.
This scaling dependency suggests some applications where the kryoff method can be useful and others where it likely
will not be. Some Hamiltonians have high complexity when mapped to cubits involving many non-commuting polystrings
that cannot easily be partitioned into a few commuting groups.
This is often true of quantum chemistry problems. For example, this complexity presents two primary challenges for
near-term quantum computers. First, the estimation of each element of H till day becomes computationally expensive due to
the large number of terms. Second, the required troder circuits become prohibitively deep. Both of these points
will be less problematic when quantum computers reach fault tolerance, but they must be considered in the near term. Even systems with simpler mappings
than those in quantum chemistry may experience the same impediments if the Hamiltonians have too many non-commuting
terms. The Kryof method is most useful where the Hamiltonian can be partitioned into relatively few commuting poly
groupoups and where H is easy to implement in troder circuits. Both of these conditions are satisfied. For
example, for many lattice models of interest in physics, KQD is especially useful if very little is known about the
ground state. This stems from its inherent convergence guarantees and its applicability in scenarios where
alternative methods are untenable due to insufficient ground state knowledge.
While KQD is a powerful tool, the protocol's time-consuming aspects, particularly the estimation of each
element of the projected Hamiltonian and the overlap of Kryof states, represent opportunities for an improvement. An
alternative approach involves approximating the kryoff state using troder circuits, then sampling the
approximated state to obtain a projection onto the computational basis and then projecting h onto the subspace
spanned by these computational basis states.
In cases where it is applicable, this methodology known as sampling based kryof quantum diagonalization SKQD
potentially offers significant reductions in time and resource requirements compared to traditional KQD.
The integration of Kryof subspace techniques with sampling methods in SKQD represents an exciting frontier in
quantum algorithms.